a muslim man claiming to have a bomb
took a rabbi and three other jews
hostage on saturday at a synagogue in
texas fortunately the standoff ended
with all of the hostages safe and only
the attacker dead after law enforcement
stormed the building there are many
lessons to learn from this incident but
the liberal establishment wants us to
learn one lesson above all others
that is the urgent need
to fight islamophobia
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
north show
[Music]
welcome back to the michael knowles show
i'm michael knowles my favorite comment
from friday is from virtual nomad who
says does the pr for biden think that
allowing kamala some air time
will make biden's awful approval ratings
seem less concerning
yes it does i know you you probably
intended that as a joke but yes that is
the theory
the theory is that joe biden is not very
popular he doesn't seem very with it he
doesn't seem like a great president but
he has a vice president who is much less
likable than he is and there have been a
number of presidents throughout history
who have used this
theory but that's certainly the case the
greatest argument against impeaching joe
biden is
kamala harris
you know that's
you know in a presidency that has so
many downsides that's one
upside that the president can count on
when you want an upside amid such crazy
turmoil i would strongly recommend you
check out get upside are you spending
too much money on gas if you live in
america right now yes chances are you
are
probably spending a little more money
than you'd like to be on gas what if i
told you that you can save 25 cents per
gallon you get cash back 25 cents for
every single
gallon that you use to fill up with get
upside it's a free app you download it
what would you say if i told you that
you'd probably say michael you're a liar
well actually in fairness
i haven't told you the whole story
because because you can actually save 50
cents per gallon
on your first fill up if you use code
nulls know w l e s go to get upside
right now get the free get upside up for
every gallon of gas that you buy you
will get
25 cents per gallon cash back and on
your first fill up it will be 50 cents
per gallon cash back super easy to get
the money
goes right into your bank account or you
can use paypal
or an amazon gift card however you want
to do it there's no catch only cash back
go to get upside right now
you download that free app use promo
code knowles know w l e s save
50 cents per gallon on your first fill
up you will get that cash back code
knowles
k-n-o-w-l-e-s
you know how much i hate to say i told
you so you know how much i hate to be
right
in my guesses and predictions and
suspicions
but i knew when i saw this story trend
that said hostages taken at a synagogue
in texas
i knew that the guy taking the hostages
was not a white guy
i knew it
i knew it i knew he wasn't a christian
nationalist or a white supremacist i
knew i knew it i knew he wasn't a white
guy at all i knew he wasn't a christian
at all do you know how i knew
because they didn't specify in the
headlines
this is known as coulter's law
named after ann coulter ann coulter's
law is that the longer it takes the news
media to identify a mass shooter in the
united states you can broaden that out
to attacker terrorists or whatever you
like
the less likely
it is to be a white male
and that was the case
here i was looking at all of the
headlines said
attacker comes okay attacker what kind
okay if it had been
a white guy or a christian
or a trump supporter or any politically
incorrect category you would have seen
that
right there in the headlines so i'm
looking and i can't find any details
about this guy finally i see
british national
takes hostages at the sit i said a
british national huh
something tells me this isn't
lord ingleburberry or something
something tells me
because they're doing whatever they can
to hide the politically incorrect fact
that this was a muslim guy
and so i look and what's the name malik
faisal akram okay malik faisal akram
doesn't sound like a methodist
doesn't sound like a presbyterian but
they won't because of the threat of
islamophobia which we'll get to in a
second the fbi then is interviewed after
this deck fortunately it has a happy
ending the hostages are released no
one's hurt other than the guy who was
committing the attack
the fbi is asked okay what motivated
this attack they they shrug their
shoulders they see we have no idea what
could have motivated this attack on
the synagogue
we do believe from our engagement with
this subject that he was singularly
focused on one issue
and it was not specifically related to
the jewish community
but we're continuing to work to find
motive and we will continue on that path
in terms of the resolution of the
incident
the hostage taker is deceased okay
singularly focused on one issue
but we're not going to tell you what
that issue is and don't worry it's not
related to the jews and anyway let's
just move on well hold on you know what
the issue is you're saying this attacker
was singing he had this one single focus
but take our word for it we the fbi we
would never mislead you
we the fbi don't want it
so let's just do a little google search
what what is the issue okay the issue is
that that this attacker wanted to free
aifiya siddiqui
who is currently serving an 86-year
sentence for attempting to kill us
troops and fbi officers
siddiqui is
an al-qaeda terrorist
not only
a terrorist but specifically associated
with
al-qaeda but this is not related to the
jews right we you can take our except
hold on
siddiqui during her trial
for the terrorism she dismissed her
legal defense team because she said that
the lawyers were jews and she demanded
that she demanded i kid you not that the
jurors in the trial take dna tests to
prove that they were not themselves jews
because that would be unfair
if they were to judge her
she said quote
it is this cruel ungrateful backstabbing
of the jews that has caused them to be
mercilessly expelled from wherever they
gain strength this is why holocausts in
quote keep happening to them repeatedly
if they would only learn to be grateful
and change their behavior
and then after her conviction for the
terrorism she said this is a verdict
coming from israel and not america
that's where the anger
belongs so
i'm no forensic investigator okay i'm no
i
i'm not an fbi i think this might have
something to do with the jews
it might specifically but we we just
don't know is that how can we know there
just aren't enough joe biden said this
joe biden was asked about the attack he
said we just
don't have enough facts
well no i don't we don't have i don't
think there is
sufficient information to know about
why he
targeted that synagogue why he insisted
on the release of someone who's been in
prison for over 10 years why he was
engaged why he
was using anti-semitic and anti-israeli
comments
i i we just don't have enough facts
we just don't know
i mean he told us
his reasoning and the terrorists that he
was trying to free told us her reasoning
and it was pretty clear
but we just got to wait a little longer
just to get all the facts this is joe
biden
who
you will recall
accused kyle rittenhouse of being a
white supremacist in a campaign ad kyle
rittenhouse just based on a little video
of him shooting
what we now know to be his attackers
his white attackers by the way
in kenosha wisconsin joe biden says he's
a white supremacist he says this is an
example of white supremacy didn't wait
for the facts to come out in that case
kyle rittenhouse
a white guy a white kid actually
but in this case well we just don't know
the muslim terrorists said he didn't
like the jews and the muslim terrorist
was trying to free said she didn't like
the jews and then they took a bunch of
jews out but we don't
if only we had more information
when facts go along with the liberal
narrative they are promoted
when facts can plausibly be
contorted
and exaggerated and changed out right
even to go along with the liberal
narrative
they are promoted
such as kyle written kyle rittenhouse
was present at a blm rally
riot i suppose and was chased away by
people and then he fired back in
self-defense
okay we can maybe we can get away with
calling him a racist that's that's how
that works when facts contradict the
liberal narrative even when they are
demonstrable facts you got it in writing
you got them dead to rights
it's much more frequent that that
happens those facts are suppressed
that's how it works
any even hint
of
a fact
or
the semblance of a fact that can justify
the liberal narrative you're going to
see it on cnn msnbc new york times
washington post it's going to be
everywhere the president of the united
states is going to be promoting it
if a terror attack occurs that
contradicts the liberal narrative it's
just gonna nothing to see here move
along move along move along
and here's the argument by the way the
argument is
yes there are a lot of muslim terror
attacks
yes
this is a big problem in america and on
american interests abroad but but
if we admit that
and it's it's i'm in this case we're
talking about muslim terror attacks but
this is true of other issues as well in
society having nothing to do with
muslims or terrorism
the argument is if we accept and admit
certain facts then americans will turn
into a savage band of animals murderous
animals into lynch mobs that will just
go around and kill innocent people who
happen to have the same race or religion
or geography or what have you
so we have to suppress the facts so that
those animal americans don't turn into a
roving band of lynch mobs here is what
wadjihat ali who is a liberal journalist
from the daily beast he tweeted out
right away right after the event i i
actually think the terror attack may
have still been going on
he tweeted out the important lesson he
said you're about to hear some ugly and
vicious islamophobia and anti-muslim
bigotry this weekend from elected
officials commentators and even
mainstream media hope i'm wrong people
will use it to divide jewish and muslim
communities for the political agenda
don't fall for it this is a man who if
you just if you just search on twitter
rajahat ali christian
you will see rank disgusting
anti-christian bigotry christianity the
most persecuted religion in the world
but per a study from pew research center
and per common sense and per historical
understanding of the last 2000 years
you will see
hideous bigotry against white guys
you'll hear white christian nationalism
white christian supremacy he says we've
got to get get rid of it from we've got
it completely blotted out from the
country these white christians they're
such a big problem
because if we don't you're going to see
the islamophobia you're going to see all
the terrible oppression of this one
group the only group that it is
legal to discriminate against and that
it is socially encouraged to
discriminate against it's the opposite
of what we're told
is the case
the absolute opposite got to clean it up
got to clean up society from all this
nastiness all this bigotry
when i want to clean my house i turn to
naturally it's clean if you've been in
the store recently any store you'll
notice that the cost of everything is
going through the roof i've noticed this
especially when i go to the grocery
store or the drugstore and i want to buy
cleaning supplies well
we have a solution for you and it's a
really phenomenal solution our partner
naturally it's clean
naturally it's clean is the best
cleaning supply
i have ever used i love it it's amazing
their secret is plant-based enzymes so
it's natural it's not going to
you know fill your house with toxins or
anything like that it's natural it's
totally safe
it's good for kids it's good for pets
but it's really going to work it's going
to get your home really really clean
whether it's carpet whether that's for
countertops whatever and it's going to
really help save you a lot of time and
money not only because they've got these
great cleaning supplies at a very fair
price but because they will use
concentrates so one bottle of their
concentrate can can give you up to 12
bottles of cleaning supplies it's really
good for the environment it's really
good for your
pocketbook and it's really really good
to help clean your home try them right
now
my listeners can get their hands on the
naturally it's clean daily wire
essential kit that is stocked with four
great products for fifteen percent off
visit naturallyitsclean.com
michael m-i-c-h-a-e-l use promo code
michael m-i-c-h-a-e-l to save an
additional fifteen percent off your
order do not delay a break from bite
inflation is here
try out these incredible cleaning
products in your home today by visiting
naturallyitsclean.com
michael m-i-c-h-a-e-l for more
information
we'll move on to the the political
significance of this
beyond just the attack on on the
synagogue in texas but what it shows
what the reaction of the media show you
is that their narrative is the opposite
of true
right their their narrative is that
muslims are being attacked all over the
country muslims can't go
black people are being attacked all over
the country lebron james said a black
man can't walk outside his door without
being hunted down by a racist cop the
argument is that
women and people of aberrant sexual
desires and also all these sorts of
victim groups they are really under
attack in america they're so put upon
they're so persecuted
but what the reaction tells you is it's
just the opposite it's just the opposite
there's only one race
that it is legal to discriminate against
sort of with a slight exception because
the asians also get it too
in affirmative action in college
admissions
but otherwise it's white people you're
told that if you're white you get a
privilege but actually you're at a
disadvantage when you're applying to
jobs when you're applying to college
there's only one religion that it is
socially acceptable
and politically and legally even
practicable to discriminate against
what's that
christianity
that's the only one that is socially
there are attacks on the jews there are
attacks on muslims
but those are always roundly condemned
by all of our political leaders by every
branch of society the only group that it
is socially acceptable and often
encouraged to mock to insult and to
persecute
christians
it's the only one in the west the only
sex that you're allowed to criticize and
attack and insult socially what is it
it's men who allegedly have all the
privilege the reality is the opposite of
what we're being told now speaking of
the jews
there is a gubernatorial candidate in
florida named nikki freed she's the
democrat who's going up against ron
desantis for governor
nikki freed has an interesting theory
that pertains to the jews and political
persecution and her theory is
that ron desantis is a lot like hitler
he is doing everything possible to take
away power from local governments taking
away people's abilities to protest
making it harder to vote talking about
you know banning books um that's what
dictators do um instead of listening and
trying to govern with the people he's
trying to govern over the people and you
know that i'm sorry you know i i'm a
student of history too i saw the rise of
hitler i learned of those stories are
you comparing desantis to hitler in a
lot of ways yes i have studied hitler
and how he got to power you know wanting
his own militia and having his own there
are other states that have one
absolutely but the reason why this
governor wants it is different than the
other states that have been utilizing it
for emergency purposes this governor is
doing it for the sole purposes of power
and in doing so to make fear and to
instill that to blame people for what is
happening in their lives blaming certain
parts of our society and our culture and
that's exactly what what hitler did to
the jews back you know during um world
war ii
i'm no phd in history okay i'm not an
academic
historian
but i don't think that's exactly what
hitler did to the jews back during world
war ii correct me if i'm wrong if you're
out there and you you have more
expertise on the side i don't think that
the desantis policies in florida
you know change the curricula a little
bit reform the curricula keep some
businesses open maybe don't don't allow
the mask mandates
i don't think that's exactly the same
thing as what hitler did to the jews in
world war ii i don't know i just think
there might be some differences i guess
is what i'm saying
obviously this woman is not
very intelligent
nikki freed and is not particularly
educated
and she is doing what the entire left
and many people on the right do which is
compare everyone they don't like to
hitler because hitler is the only
historical figure that they even think
they know anything about and they
probably don't even know very much about
world war ii or
the 20th century or dictatorship in the
past century but it's the one that they
think they know something about hitler
and occasionally they'll reference the
fall of rome
there are more historical events
most people are not like hitler usually
hitler comparisons are not particularly
illuminating and it shows something else
as well
which is
that
no one ever says this this candidate is
so bad he's just like stalin
this candidate is so bad he's just like
mao
this this candidate this politician is
so bad he's a lot like che guevara
he's a lot like fidel castro very rarely
do you hear those comparisons
you only hear
people
disparagingly compared to
bad political figures who can
plausibly be lumped onto the right
even though obviously it's more
complicated with the nazi party because
it has elements of the right but it's
also got elements of leftism and it's
very modern and anyway you could go on
for hours about that but you you never
hear the comparisons made
disparagingly to politicians and
dictators and tyrants who are firmly on
the left because
because the liberals won they won
they've won
our politics they rule the country the
conservatives have
some modicum of dissent and some slight
ability to push back a little bit but we
are clearly the junior partner in the
way that this country is ruled and so
all bad things have to be on the right
and no really really bad things are ever
on the left
that's way that's that's the way that
that works
now
there are
there is some hope here there is some
hope coming back which is that we are
winning some elections and republicans
are finally gaining a spine and and
courage and they're pushing back on the
liberal policies namely
glenn yonkin in virginia glenn younkin
first day in office he was just sworn in
first in office bans critical race
theory in schools bans mass mandates in
schools and his attorney general fired i
think 30 some odd
officials in that office
and is now prom very liberal officials
who weren't prosecuting crime and he is
now promising to prosecute the criminals
who the local george soros funded da's
are going to let off the hook this is
good this is really good news from glenn
younkin this is the future of the
conservative movement and the republican
party it is good in and of itself that
younkin is doing these things
but it's also a sign of what people want
it's also a sign of where the political
winds are shifting
do not forget glenn younkin first ran
for governor as a standard issue
run-of-the-mill business republican who
promised to cut your taxes and leave you
alone that was the early pitch for his
campaign his campaign only shifted in
the final weeks to a culture warrior
campaign
that focused on critical race theory and
transgenderism in schools and the
gender-neutral bathrooms it became this
very intense cultural conservative
campaign only in the final weeks and
that's what pushed him over the finish
line what got him over the finish line
was not a surge in republican voter
registration in in virginia which is
overwhelmingly democrat what pushed him
over the finish line is parents
not parents who were concerned about
their taxes primarily parents who didn't
want their kids to be raped in the
school bathroom and didn't want their
kids to be told that white people are
evil because of the way they're born and
kids to be told that little johnny can
become little jill if he wants to and
and should be able to mutilate his
bodies and pretend to be the other sex
that's what did it culture and young can
realize that he switched his campaign
and he won
he won as a culture warrior now he is
signaling that he's going to govern like
ron desantis i wonder why maybe because
ron desantis is the most popular
republican governor in the country and
is considered one of the leading
presidential contenders in 2024. you
think that might have something to do
with it i suspect it will this actually
this is really good news for the
conservative movement and really good
news for the republican party but it
creates a problem for ron desantis which
is right now when you just look at the
governors
ron desantis is the only ron desantis
he's the only republican governor who is
really out there in every single
national news story getting his name in
it on the right side of the issue
pushing back leading the charge
as we get closer to 2024 i think you're
going to see a lot of rhonda sampus
copycats
and
ron desantis deserves credit for being
the first guy there
but when you're looking at 2024 what
happens if you've got a field
where all the governors are ron desantis
the governors and the senators and the
congressmen other people are going to
run too but
they're it's kind of comparing apples
and oranges because they just do
different things in government but if
you've got a field where all the
governors are ron desantis
that's a little tough then to
distinguish yourself other than saying i
was first so they're going to have to
all keep it up they're going to have to
go further they're going to have to keep
fighting and this is
though i'm sorry for governor desantis
that it might make his campaign a little
tougher this is really great news for
the conservative movement the republican
party because now
all of the political pressure
is pushing these governors
toward courage toward the right towards
standing up for true substantive things
and not just the same dumb republican
platitudes we've heard for 20 years
really good
news speaking of power politics there's
a movie that a lot of people were
watching over the weekend and it was
trending all around
twitter and things like that this is the
tragedy of macbeth
the tragedy of macbeth it was a movie
version based on macbeth by shakespeare
starring denzel washington and francis
mcdormand
and it was slightly controversial
because as you might
recognize denzel washington is not a
particularly well-known scotsman
and the play is about a scottish king
but i decided i was going to sit down
was going to watch the movie
joel cohen one of the greatest living
directors denzel washington one of the
greatest living actors francis mcdormand
one of the greatest living actresses and
macbeth one of the greatest plays ever
written you will be unsurprised to hear
it was a very very good movie and i
thought when i was
watching this movie about an extremely
corrupt political order that is based on
treachery sometimes outright murder that
rips the polity asunder and and leads to
horrible problems for the whole society
i thought huh
this might have something to tell us
about our country today maybe more
people maybe that's the reason they made
the movie in the first place
now
we'll get to more on that in one second
but speaking of movies i'm very excited
to announce the release of the daily
wires first original production we
released a movie that had already been
made last year and we bought the
distribution rights because people were
trying to cancel it so that was our
first movie this is our first original
movie it's called shut in it is a seat
gripping thriller that will be available
to stream in february follows the story
of a young mother who's barricaded
inside a closet by her violent
ex-husband as she's trapped inside she
uses nothing but her voice to guide her
children on the other side of the walls
to safety all while the threat of her
dangerous ex looms so go check it out
it's really cool
we cannot wait to share the finished
product with you so make sure you catch
the final trailer when it drops tomorrow
it's gonna be a lot of fun if you're
planning on adding this terrifying
thriller to your queue you want us to
keep making that content that the
mainstream media do not want to produce
then go like and share the trailer on
youtube your support makes all the
difference also we're gonna have
backstage finally again dw is one of the
first in the nation to file suit against
the biden administration on their
unconstitutional osha vaccine mandate
our case made it to the supreme court
and we won
tune in tomorrow night to catch an
all-new episode of backstage where we
discuss the outcome of that supreme
court ruling it's going to be wonderful
we're going to drink a lot of leftist
tears it's going to be me ben jeremy
matt and drew 7 p.m 6 p.m central
dailywire.com or
you can stream it on our youtube channel
dailywire we'll be right back with a lot
more
welcome back to the show
i really loved this movie the tragedy of
macbeth it's kind of an artsy film it's
black and white
it's
an ambitious adaptation
it's minimalist and it's set design
but it's it's artsy so if you don't like
artsy movies this is not going to be the
movie for you but it is one of the
greatest plays ever written by the
greatest english playwright with some of
the greatest living actors and actresses
and the greatest director so it's really
wonderful the one controversy of it was
that denzel washington obviously is not
scottish he's a black guy
so should a black guy be allowed to play
a white part and is this woke and is
this politically correct
the debate over colorblind casting is an
extremely complicated one
it's it's not a simple answer one way or
the other folks this has been a debate
that's gone on for decades one of the
great proponents of color blind casting
was a guy named bob it is a guy named
bob brewstein who was the founder of the
l repertory theater and
uh
is a sort of legend in the theater world
he's a white guy he's a big proponent of
color blind casting having black people
play white parts and
not taking into account of an actor's
ethnicity
august wilson who's probably the most
famous black playwright of the last
hundred years maybe the most famous
black playwright in american history he
hated colorblind casting he said black
people should not play white parts white
people should not play black parts this
is insane
race
involves
lots of cultural aspects and it's you
can't suspend disbelief and you
shouldn't do it
there's also this double standard now
which is that white actors not white
actors are not allowed to play any
non-white parts and if they are there's
a big uproar and the woke people scream
about it
white actors are not even allowed to
voice non-white parts
the white actor who voiced apu on the
simpsons got got cancelled from the part
because you're not allowed to do that
anymore so yes there's a double standard
it's it's preposterous it's silly
however
if you can get past all of the stupid
woke stuff and just recognized that
denzel washington is one of the greatest
living actors and his performance in
this movie is just incredible then i
think
you can tune out all of the noise
furthermore you can say that shakespeare
is writing about not specific issues
only related to scotland but he's
writing about the human condition and
therefore it makes a lot more sense for
a black guy to play
that role even though it's a scottish
role really the play is about the human
condition whereas if you had denzel
washington starring in the the remake of
the sopranos that probably wouldn't make
a lot of sense what it the sopranos is
very specifically about an
italian-american family so it wouldn't
make sense to have a non-italian actor
play that part okay that's a little bit
of the controversy around it the reason
i even bring up the movie though
is because the play is about
fate versus free will
and the movie joel cohen really brings
this out
macbeth
opens up the play one of the very first
things in the play is walking up and he
sees a a bunch of witches and the
witches tell him his future and they say
you're going to become king but you're
not going to have a line of kings
and tells his partner banquo
you're not going to be king but your
kids are going to become king and
this is going to happen and this is
going to happen and macbeth is struck
with this and he says well hold on if
all of this is going first of all do i
believe these witches that that's really
going to happen and then he sees some
proof that some of their predictions
came true he says well okay if it's
going to happen then i guess i don't
need to do anything
he says if chance will have me king why
chance may crown me without my story i'm
not going to do anything about it but
then he does do something about he says
and mostly because his wife lady macbeth
is just an early version of hillary
clinton and she's this sort of wicked
political character who just
it impels him and convinces him to kill
the king and become king himself and so
he does participate in it but was that
always faded or did he really have free
choice and by the end he and his hillary
clinton wife go completely insane
and he's he's she becomes extremely
depressed he becomes very depressed he
can't sleep anymore because he killed
the king in his sleep he says he says
sleep no more macbeth does murder sleep
i'll never sleep again because one he
saw the king dying asleep and two
because he's racked by the moral reality
of what he's done
he's one of the most famous
lines of the entire place is tomorrow
and tomorrow and tomorrow creeps in this
petty pace from day to day to the last
syllable of recorded time and all our
yesterdays have lighted fools the way to
dusty death outbrief candle life's but a
walking shadow a poor player that struts
and frets his hour upon the stage and
then is heard no more it is a tale told
by an idiot full of sound and fury
signifying nothing that's what
a lot of people think life is today
that's what they think that it's all
just kind of a joke it's all just kind
of a farce a tale told by an idiot
signifying nothing our hopes our dreams
our loves our joys it's all just an
illusion man you know it's just
chemicals firing off in our brain
and it's just and by the way if you if
you don't like how you're feeling just
take a pill and then you'll feel better
or just do do some
other drugs or just go have sex with
somebody or go some you know sort of
casual sex or just go have a drink or
just go play video games or just plug
into the metaverse or just just give
yourself pleasure because that's all it
is it doesn't mean anything
but what macbeth and his wife realize
after they've committed this horrible
sin
is that the sin really does mean
something another one of the most famous
lines is you've got hillary clinton
there lady macbeth and she's saying out
damn spot out she's trying to rub out
the sp rub out the blood rub out what
she's done but she can't she can't
forget it macbeth can't sleep because he
can't forget what he actually did
because it does signify something it
does life actually does matter the
things we do there is a moral universe
and we're living in an age where we try
to blot all that out and we say that
everything is just about
power
at the left says that politics is just
different interest groups
and usually they push interest groups on
racial or sexual lines it's just them
vying for power and there's no sense and
there's no order and there's no truth
and there's no justice and there's no
goodness it's just interest and power
and frankly you have people on the right
saying almost the same thing it's
amazing that it's the conservatives who
for the past 30 years have said all life
is about his money and just boosting gdp
and cutting taxes and you do you and
we're not going to legislate morality
and don't yuck my yum
and who's to say what's good i mean they
sound just like the liberals
and they all sound like
macbeth and lady macbeth and that's why
we live in a crappy country right now
because we need to recognize
that life actually does signify
something that's how we will have better
sleep that is how we will have a better
country that is how we will rub out that
damn spot is by recognizing that there's
a moral order there is sin there is
grace there is truth there is falsehood
there is goodness there is evil and
there is redemption if only we seek it
speaking of madness speaking of madness
there's a viral video going around of a
gal who
is going to transition she's going to
have the gender surgery she's a woman
now but she's going to make herself look
more like a man because she says that
the men who are living in her brain
want that so she doesn't want that she
the woman but the men living in her
brain do want her to do that and so
that's what they are going to do
so i'm a member of a did system and for
me right now that means that in the
coming months i am going to be able to
watch some of my best friends and some
of my closest companions get the body of
their dreams that matches their gender
that makes them feel happy and in
exchange
i'm gonna have to give up my own i'm
cisgender the majority of my handmaids
aren't and we've decided to transition
which means that as happy as i am for
the men in my system i am about to have
to watch myself go through the wrong
puberty uh
and it's gonna be permanent i don't
think we talk enough about how did gets
rid of a person's bodily autonomy you
know i hear people say all the time the
one thing you have control over is your
own body and your own reactions and i
don't have that this isn't my body these
aren't my reactions or my memories i
have like 30 people living in my brain
and everything i do belongs to us as a
group that's what's so hellish about
this disorder my parents
and now i will never have full bodily
autonomy anyways um everybody say
congratulations to the men in my system
because they get to transition and we're
happy for them so this woman
and i say this with as much
sympathy as there is in the world is
completely insane and she is
acknowledging that she's saying i have
this
this mental condition called did a
google did d.i.d is a dissociative
identity disorder so multiple
personalities all floating around in her
imagination
and she says that a lot of them are men
and the men want her to mutilate her
body
in the olden days
this this was attributed to more
spiritual causes you might recall
reading in the bible when you go up to
someone
and they start speaking with multiple
personalities and they say we are legion
and this was considered not a very good
thing and something to be fixed rather
than indulge
today we indulge it
and so
this woman says i've got 10 different
men living in my brain
and therefore i'm transgender and
we're going to
change my body
when she goes to the doctor and says
i've got 10 men living in my brain the
doctor says okay well you've got this
disorder
dissociative identity disorder we're
going to treat that disorder she says
okay and i'm transgender i'm really a
man and the doctor says oh well okay
let's chop you up then
why
why are we acknowledging that one of
these mental illnesses is a mental
illness and why are we pretending that
the other one is
perfectly normal and and just an
ordinary aspect of one's identity
if if a single person
walks up and says i'm actually 10 people
we acknow for now at least we
acknowledge that that's not true and
crazy and you should treat that
but if a woman walks up and says i'm
actually a man
we
until
three or four years ago we would say no
that's not true that's crazy and we
would try to treat that now we just say
okay buddy let's go hunting
let's go let's let's do it pal you want
to go play a round of golf
it doesn't seem to make a lot of sense
to me why is one of these crazy and the
other one legitimate they were both in
the dsm they were both in the
in the catalog of mental illnesses until
very recently how come one of them got
taken out
because transgenderism is ideologically
and politically convenient for the left
in this country and so we're turning
something that is manifestly a disorder
into
a political tool
fairly disturbing speaking of disturbing
videos going around to the internet
there's a an even more disturbing one if
you can believe it than than the woman
with multiple demonic figures in her
head that would be a kid who was on tick
tock with his mother and said that his
mother
is going to make him join the lgbtq
community
does your mom say you have to be lgbt
i'm not no i think she's what i want to
be but some
fun
go ahead let's fight keep talking stay
with yourself
my mom doesn't matter if i'm up if i am
gay or a lesbian or any of that she
doesn't care all she cares about is that
i'm a part of it
and if i'm not a part of it she'll try
to convince me to i'm get join it
because i
what are you saying right though
facts that i would convince you to join
what the eligibility plus
this is bad
obviously we're blurring the kids faces
unlike this abusive mother who's putting
her kids on the internet for her own
edification and pleasure and gain
but you can see when the kid starts to
answer this question the other kid looks
at the mother
and says whoo and the other kid he puts
his hand he says don't maybe you don't
answer that the kid says no it's okay
it's just my mom she doesn't care if i'm
a lesbian or gay or transgender or
whatever she just wants me to be one of
them
i've just got to be part of it i've just
got to be in some way part of the lgbt
community and then the mother says huh
wait hold on she realizes this answer's
not going the way she wanted it to
when she put her kids on screen
and she she says what are you talking
about what are you saying he says facts
obviously you want me to do that and so
this was put out by libs of tick tock
which is now reporting
that the mother is apparently quite
involved in the lgbtq community and has
some kind of romantic relationship with
some kind of transgender type so she's
obviously promoting this sort of stuff
people are shocked
that the kid would say this people are
shocked that a mother would do of course
i'm not shocked at all
being in the lgbt
lmnop community carries social currency
i know that the
liberal establishment pretends
that to be in the lgbt lmnop comes with
lots of sacrifice and and terrible
burdens and that it's you're actually a
persecuted minority but that's not the
case
every
power center in this country
promotes
lgbtq if you
disparage lgbtq
even the crazy even the even the tea
which is the craziest part of all
if you
disparage that you will be censored
often you will be de-platformed often
you could face professional
repercussions you could be fired you
could be kicked out of school
depending on exactly how you do it you
might face some criminal penalties
you can't do that
you're not allowed it's one of the most
protected groups in the country
actually
the only group that you are allowed to
discriminate against legally the only
group
sexual group that you're allowed to
and encouraged to publicly insult and
attack is what it's
straight people
that's it it's the opposite of what the
libs are telling us
on race on sex on religion on the entire
political order all of the powerful
institutions are telling you
this group is really persecuted and this
group is doing the persecuting and so
well what's the effect of that the
effect of that is when all of the power
centers are smearing one group and are
lauding another group and
protecting another group and
giving advantage to another group then
then the groups are actually flipped
then the one that we're told is
persecuted is not it's powerful and the
one that we're told is powerful is
actually
persecuted that's the way these things
work
speaking of bad moms
the new york times has another
distressing story
this also this really also kind of comes
back to macbeth to our macbeth culture
to lady macbeth in particular
the new york times is defending moms
abandoning their kids
this is from the culture sections
they're talking about all these new
movies where moms are just leaving their
kids and all these new stories and books
where moms abandon their kids they write
the mother who abandons her children
haunts our family narratives she's made
into a lurid tabloid figure an exotic
exception
to the common deadbeat father or she is
sketched into the background of a plot
her absence lending a protagonist a
propulsive origin story this figure
arouses our ridicule ridicule consider
meryl streep's daffy american president
and don't look up who forgets to save
her son as she flees the apocalypse or
our pity
see parallel mothers where an actress
has ditched her daughter for lousy
television parts but lately the
vanishing mother has provoked a fresh
response
respect
because they say the one thing a mother
cannot do in our culture the one thing
she cannot do the thing that is so taboo
it rivals actually murdering her
offspring is leave
now the argument doesn't seem to make a
lot of sense because they're referencing
movies that still look on the mother
abandoning her children with scorn and
pity like meryl streep's movie where she
abandons her son meryl streep is not
exactly a sympathetic figure in don't
look up which i did a review of by the
way that you can catch on youtube
but why is this
why is it that mothers abandoning their
children arouses our scorn and our pity
and our heartbreak
is it just our prejudice is it just our
sexism
or is it that mothers abandoning their
children horrifies us because it is
horrifying
is it different
when a mother abandons her kid than when
you have a deadbeat dad who also
deadbeat dads are also looked on with
scorn and disdain and pity and so
but but it's different i grant you it's
different
is it that mothers who abandon their
kids are looked on as different than
dads who abandon their kids because moms
and dads are different
yeah that's how human beings have
understood moms and dads for all of
recorded history everywhere in the world
until five minutes ago because now we
have to pretend that moms and dads are
exactly the same
we're doing my show from home right now
because
global warming reared its ugly head in
nashville and so the whole city is
covered in ice and because nashville is
not accustomed to snow and doesn't know
how to deal with it a little bit of ice
means we do our shows from home okay so
i've got my wife and my child
outside of my office here
i play around with my kid i go see the
kid during the day you know i want to
gucci goo him and he likes it it's full
play for a little bit
but you know what he likes more than
hanging out with dad he likes hanging
out with mommy
and
when he's just sort of sitting playing
having fun then he'll play with dad but
when he really wants something when he's
in distress when he's hungry when he's
tired when he's when he just wants
comfort you know where he turns he
doesn't turn to daddy he turns to mommy
because mommy and daddy are different
we're physically different we're
different in our relation to the baby
we're different
spiritually metaphysically emotionally
we're just different okay but since the
sexual revolution we've had to pretend
that men and women are exactly the same
you saw this first with the second wave
feminists
who said a woman needs a man like a fish
needs a bicycle said all of the virtues
now are masculine virtues all of the
feminine virtues are trash so women have
to go work in the widget factory just
like men and any woman who wants to stay
home should not be allowed to do it
that's what simone de beauvoir one of
the most prominent feminists of that era
said she said women can't even be given
that choice because too often they'll
take it and then they won't be liberated
so it starts with the second wave
feminists it moves on to the gay rights
movement which says that men and women
are exactly the same and once we
accepted once we accepted that premise
then almost inevitably you were going to
redefine marriage because if men and
women are exactly the same then the
union of one man and one woman is
exactly the same as the union of one man
and one man is exactly the same as the
union between one woman and one woman
but once you accept that then you've got
to accept transgenderism because if men
and women are exactly the same then
there's no reason that a man can't
become a woman and a woman can't become
a man
women tried to transform themselves into
men in the 1970s they did it without the
surgeries usually but they certainly did
it socially they certainly did it
emotionally they tried at least and so
when you've got the technology to chop
people up and make them look a little
bit more like the other sex why would
you not do that too
and now you've got the culture lauding
mothers who abandoned their kids
because why because
men and women are exactly the same they
i don't think they would lawed fathers
who abandoned their kids by the way but
they would laud mothers for doing that
also because
the power and the privilege are not
exactly what the liberal establishment
tells us but this is evidence that
something has gone horrifically wrong in
society
and that's a consequence of sexual
confusion and it's a consequence by the
way of an obsession with individualism
that does not merely exist on the right
on the left it exists on the right as
well you see it on the left where they
say that
anyone's individual appetites especially
sexual appetites but others as well for
drugs and food and
and all sorts of things should be
indulged and none of them are wrong this
is why you see the movement for fat
positivity and sex positivity and all
the rest of it
drug legalization and you see it on the
right as well you see it on the right
with
money you see it on the right even with
certain kinds of behavior you leave me
alone you lit you know you do you if it
doesn't affect me if it doesn't scare
the horses in the street then you can do
whatever you want that's not my business
just cut taxes and and do whatever you
want behind closed doors none of that is
conservative none of that is conducive
to a good polity it's just not gonna
work
now speaking of scientific reality
i've got to get to one story because i
think it's so important that we all
rally the troops here
joe rogan is under fire
they are tr the libs are trying to
cancel joe rogan
joe rogan is under fire
because he is giving a platform to
scientists who dissent from the liberal
establishment
people like robert malone dr robert
malone who helped to develop mrna
technology who's now skeptical of the
vaccines so anyway there is now a
petition an open letter from 300
scientists
telling spotify to get rid of joe rogan
so we took a little look into these 300
scientists it's a great uh luke
rudkowski
posted some of them let's see we've got
the director of research at grasshopper
farms cole creighton we've got colleen
tricarton frost she's a dentist we've
got courtney kennedy a physician's
assistant we've got crystal palula a
nurse practitioner we've got
uh daniel jones a consultant we've got
daniel levitt a postdoc so these aren't
these aren't exactly specialists they're
not exactly the top scientists in their
field some of them are dentists
they'll say joe rogan's not a scientist
sure but the scientists that he
interviews are the problem is because
they dissent from the liberal
establishment they are
they're un-personed they're not they're
no longer
scientists joe rogan is far right now
joe rogan is on the left but joe rogan
is far right now people like glenn
greenwald far right now
they're all anyone who it far right
doesn't mean you're on the right wing it
doesn't mean you're conservative it
doesn't mean
it just means you dissent
from
the established liberal
orthodoxy which is presenting to you a
reality that is completely different
from the way things actually are and
people they see it when the fbi comes
out and says the muslim terror is
screaming about jews we don't know his
motive you can see it when dr fauci
admits that he was lying about some
aspect of kovit or the or the whole
public health establishment changes you
can see it but then we keep going on we
just keep going on and i think people
are waking up a little bit to that
delusion
but
there is no way that we are going to
have a good society that we're going to
have a flourishing of free and equitable
adjust society if we continue to indulge
delusions whether they're at the
national level or whether they're the
personal level of pretending that men
are women i'm michael knowles is the
michael show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bori our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
john bickley here daley wire
editor-in-chief
wake up every morning with our show
morning wire
on today's episode inflation reaches
record levels the biden administration
faces tough questions on their
immigration policies and how omicron
changes the kovid game
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire